yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
vampire again the plate this guy two
times in recent games it wasn't it
wasn't great yeah 11 gamer was winning
right out of the opening he played a
completely busted line in the pond siani
but i forgot the refutation and this is
also very very very Viet isn't isn't
black just just fine here ok so aged 60
h5 age 59 f for ya very strange chess
let's go age 6 this is of course
comparable to the to the Knight c3 g4
variation sometimes called the vendor
via variation but here it's got the
night on d tool yep well at least done I
know that I will have something to play
play for his King position ok so can you
just take it the night is fine I'll be
six I think I can just go knight c6 97
next
I wonder maybe he needs to do something
like c4 I know I could have taken a
break windy five maybe all right that's
not to spend too much time one point of
this wacky openings is that you you
spend time you try to refute them
directly and sometimes there is no
direct refutation just the normal good
moves other the way to go and all right
so just lon castles maybe I need to put
the King somewhere so what is this
position like okay King be ages are very
routine move why should I be or can I
open open up position yeah I need to do
this first no doubt no doubt them how to
how to improve my play him f6 this
exposes the six pawn g5 takes Knight
eggs I'd like to get something against
the king of course 27 Bishop c7 is also
bad hmm so what am I playing actually
okay I'm thinking about really playing
BF porn and giving away six but I don't
want to do this running into Bishop f4
okay so he's just he's just pushing f6
young Colonel this was the idea of all
this try to open lines against the king
okay he didn't take at least so pluck f5
is going to answer with g5 if i take
night takes
it's not it's not too great
if I go g5g five takes night text this
is actually good okay he takes on f6 a
ticket for this is at least messy now if
you move to the bishop I call a go f5
with a really good position so now just
take you five yeah I need to take you
five
okay if I take it Bishop b5 his [ __ ]
so shouldn't do that I can play Queen G
sandal
maybe maybe I can play age five this
would be would be helpful or sure
somewhere I don't know it's very
complicated of course the ship c7 is
also an IDM fighting 45 also deform
maybe default yeah I'm not sure of
course it all depends on on his concrete
news and he can play all kinds of news
in four or something ok at least half an
easy he's the answer the first month at
least is clear KD 5 50 ok let's uh let's
push let's push here if he goes a 5 I go
d 30 Mike I don't have a square for this
piece I didn't really appreciate that ok
anyway oh it's uh oh no it's okay seven
mate ah this is sick this is sick ah ah
yeah ah look a seven mate okay yeah now
look a six major so threat yeah I don't
even have a trickier my son resign what
deck I mean no I don't know have a bit
i'm a bit at a loss for words here this
is this was just an unclear position
cannot cannot really say what was what
was going going on here so let say this
position I don't think that this is too
overwhelming for white maybe rook c8
yeah Bishop d7 yeah but it's got a five
and a six yeah it's tricky but I mean
this game I need to win like much
earlier or I need to get something
because never ever this is good 92 g 492
this is just bonkers but I didn't didn't
get anything yeah here why this white is
just better I mean I mean this is
impossible to be any good maybe h5 now
maybe h5 this is this is a possible idea
playing simply it's quite similar to the
night of being on c3 but i don't know i
don't really know it this is not a
theoretical line that I yet you can look
up in a book or something but the way I
played the sudden he was bad but it
wasn't wasn't a refutation or anything
maybe um
quick h5 was an idea to prevent this
this is often a bit annoying now I don't
know it's just super complicated and he
played it played it better alright
thanks for watching